bars taverns and similar businesses are
getting ready to put their bar tops back
in operation
sunday at midnight bars in southern
nevada can reopen
today we learn new protocols for
businesses that they must follow
joe mohler is live at the copper keg
that is up in the northwest
valley with the details joe
yeah hey the clock is ticking employees
are excited to welcome back the regulars
to the bar including the ones here at
the copper keg but before they can do
that
they must acknowledge new protocols that
are in place
the copper keg in the northwest valley
is getting ready
we're really excited employees have been
waiting for this news
timing should work out perfectly to be
able to put the machines back in the bar
come monday sunday at midnight the
24-hour establishment can welcome back
customers
to the bar they must follow social
distancing guidelines operate at 50
capacity bar top seating must be six
feet apart and congregation areas
including billiards and dancing areas
must remain closed
basic hygiene and cleanliness friday the
nevada restaurant association released
protocols such as an online training and
an acknowledgment form
that must be signed and present at all
locations just
more logistics and more roles that we
need to follow to keep everybody safe
and keep ourselves safe too
which we'll adjust and do what we need
to do to be able to do that
each day employees must answer simple
yes or no health questions like
if they have a fever or cough if they
answer no they can start their shift
as the kang we're very diligent about
making sure everything is clean and
sanitized and we've been doing all the
same procedures that they keep putting
into place
bartenders are excited to serve again i
know our customers miss
the social interaction and we're looking
forward to that too
like you just saw there many are excited
to get the bars back open they have a
few days to
complete that training and to get the
bar tops ready like they are here at the
copper keg and they are excited
considering monday
is the first raiders game here in las
vegas reporting live in the northwest
valley joe mohler 8 news now